hey guys welcome back to the couch
joined as usual by Lisa James and some
more Hussein and probably a bunch of
other people online because we're
playing quip lash and as soon as we get
started we're opening it up to the
Twitter's which dangerous thing I'll
live for danger my middle name is danger
Jennifer nice yeah right so we're gonna
tweet either if I start the room
sweet room code and then hopefully
people come join us all right we've got
hungry Dino yo sup Steph big boy King
and it'll be big boy also that guy
called it tomorrow sooo yeah with flash
so wait you play quickly basically you
fill in the blanks in quotes and people
vote for the funniest answer lives I
don't actually know what my lives are
but I've seen friends that's a goofy one
episode Batman Robin fighting blank just
mental
that's me that's a name for belly bones
oh wow as a hairy dude I can no no I
don't want to big boy king Oh see this
all of these I'm you just say you know
funnier a calico chuck something you
don't to hear from the guy driving your
romantic horse-drawn carriage that's a
low bridge or so today with Gina tricot
that's current bit pandering if you ask
me oh yeah is it your answer no you've
been playing this question well so then
you don't hear from the guy driving you
boy you're like oh yeah I don't get why
is that funny that how low is this
bridge that's the thing what well me my
my missing you here
I don't know I expected there to be
something fully grown yeah well well
done people playing for not pandering to
to that like a glue PVA glue do you have
a dealer thing in our custom ear in
school cover your hand in PDA and then
peel it off can't do it now okay there
we are
but when I was in tension and just
shoved in my face my textiles teacher
was 420 blaze' all
long Dennis the Menace grew up and
governor named Dennis the disappointment
or 10 is the panis
I know which one I'm going for audience
votes this poem is a day of joy for the
audience ah oh yes yes
still got some points though audience
favorite people in this audience taught
me drama clearly gunning to win an Oscar
the revenant gunning Superboy is that
jungle book or is that like he's a man
come don't try to kill me I'm making it
straight
Oh some of the city yes the audience
crush the baby audience kick the
audience it's a little yeah he'll turn
let them eat cake you know the coffee
shop barista is hitting on you when they
ask would you like room for max baristas
can't even get your name right yeah
never mind
asking raining then got in the car get
my name for video go rumpy-pumpy
clockwork you know you know they say I'm
a people pleaser
oranjee
oh yes shot lust I'm getting in there
was very pumping was Waiver pumping was
a pumpkin spice latte good Nigel
Thornberry you might find a Snapple cat
that can possibly be true greenie oh hey
I can't possibly be true yeah absolutely
what a bad undercover cop posing as a
teen says what up fellow kids you know
you guys know buy some drugs who wants
to fight my plugs yeah that's one safe
pogs he's back in park for a reenactment
a reenactor at Colonial Williamsburg
would get suspended if they said blank
are you in views online
don't be Trump or what the hell is
Williamsburg come drop them shrub so
this was the famous side of the battle
dump Trump
this is named rump
I did what Palin's or Williamsburg
especially if hungry diner who was the
more comic actor that that special move
would be this I don't even know who when
we don't know is playing yeah I know I
mean in the IR Elvis I don't know in
digest ality pumping is a good one is
that when you just can't digest food
properly you die from that
and I just a Latino what I think about
it is pretty but pomping I don't know
I just like it dies a throwback to its
previous answer oh wow the audience
swing vote big boy king over again all
right schools I think people can't go in
this in this a really dumb roundtable
discussion would be about this topic how
Ryan is a table if dogs can read the
second one I would I would very much
like about yeah maybe it's like Braille
[Music]
me Oh whitewash absolutely pasting it
was so proud of you Alan banks
good boy I mean what God probably smells
like kind of your wing
you can't wait sounds like buttered anus
or beard oil and one-night stands
Wow Wow Wow on another penis in there it
says inferno which one do you like more
[Music]
got a base get it one-night stands
because Jesus I grew up Catholic
I remember bells tell a good views 450
gallons of bacon grease bud penis
slightly the events of a school or
making the new 10 pound notes this is
week I like I like the current one
though but then this is not an option
you can't just default about anus my
life what the body I'm going for the
classic Simpsons Thank You Nelson lunch
lady Doris oh yeah got any grease yes
yes we do then grease yeah woman okie
dokie like it's in the news currently
[Music]
he's in the lead you're not taking my
crimes I'm more interested in crowns
they call me the Kingslayer another cook
book written by a cowboy it's ha there's
a steak with my boot that's pretty good
there's a snake in my boot he's really
good thank you
I don't feel bad that you just won by
taking the name of an animated movie
that stars a surfing I read likes my
great I was gonna come out a lot of
these no answer
yeah I have to keep that one not ejected
first draft line from The Shining he's
[Music]
like it's too easy I mean the other end
don't be that person
hi Stephen King says his trash so it
must be trapped I'll write the book
before I saw the movie and I said maybe
do this document it's like timely motion
[Music]
sensor my phone
peace peace but touch me I'm waiting or
find me on tinder here add me on high
five just check the second one does it
work can you make Barrett into a tinder
profile I feel it's like Shannon you
tell me you use these apps
no I live my life vote which one were
you gonna vote for touch me I'm waiting
only because it looks like me
real all these were fighting for a where
dad keeps all of his children blanks as
memories yeah my parents keep teeth I
know they're gross and it's not really
eight bodies fan letters to tomorrow
Dave and Lucy some pandering happening
here is the last time we go front line
was that time you got a letter
full stop yesterday I mean like not from
the bank you need salt professed coming
up for making YouTube coming default
default yeah he's in the lead now have
robbed I'll have an erotic movie fan
difference
fifty shades of gray actually words
perfectly trucks out what's wrong for
your bath sorry a BAM if it was actually
cool 50 shades of grey anthem never
forgets to hey Dad
Oh pip lash yeah mate smash it that's
all the elephants a novice smashed it
tap that when the stork isn't delivering
babies he making a what is making this
is bacon mm-hmm what slowly gonna win
I'm making it work shop in that
character audience one single audience
we have yes no the opposite just saw the
kind of blue move up - me did i / all
right everyone gets the same problem
this is the one that the audience might
find tricky
we went hunting you download you can see
this cosmic lash which makes it better
can teach it how do you tell we're
flying south I'm actually looking
forward to her sings answers because now
I know the audience can you see the
comic see what you can do
I'm really fuzzy dancing okay so if like
so my minimap I can't see the voice in
my head is telling me to eat you can't
see [ __ ]
Trump thank you I mean huge mistake
actually cut it works I actually want
some of these to win because you make it
fun
so the Leprechaun in my head is telling
me to burn I don't mind a jar jar binks
mom yes it is I can do Christopher
Walken I can do
oh say jaeseok passed away I'm gonna
beat the B though now beats the one B's
going to say my friend well don't be
what does it really mean though right
well that's all we got time for for this
episode if you liked the video make sure
you hit that like button
I like smash it there was some technical
difficulty how's that subscribe button
pump you in a minute now see you next
time make an M